according to sociologist Malcolm
Gladwell the equation for greatness is a
natural aptitude plus a minimum of
10,000 hours of effort
this type of egalitarian thinking
influences the way we raise our children
to believe that if they work hard and
play by the rules then success is more
or less guaranteed but what happens when
you've put in way beyond 10,000 hours
and played by the rules but then the
rules of the game are changed two-time
Olympic champion caster Semenya found
herself faced with exactly this when it
was announced last week that she had
lost her appeal against the
International Association of Athletics
Federations who had ruled that female
runners with hyperandrogenism eye
naturally occurring high testosterone
levels must take medication to suppress
it in order to compete in certain events
such discriminatory practices are not
forced upon male athletes who have
natural physical advantages take Michael
Phelps whose uniquely shaped body allows
him to cut through water faster sadly
when it comes to policing bodies in
sport just as in society the women are
the victims this might surprise the
viewers but I've never competed at the
Olympic athlete a horse man or Horseman
to the best of my knowledge to sup on
neither have you so let's turn to
someone who has and bring in Sharron
Davis yep I do
100% sympathise and I do understand and
I do believe we have to find ways around
for both intersection athletes and for
transgender women athletes as how they
can be included but we also have to work
out how can we protect women's sport
because if we're not careful in 10 years
time all the world records will be held
by men in the men's races and all the
world records in the women's races will
be held by people who have a y
chromosome and rather than bang on and
on and repeat what she says she's
broadly right I have enormous sympathy
for caster Semenya
I thought the way she reacted to the dig
to the decision showed such dignity and
grace and credit to her your analogy
with the swimmer Phelps is not fair
because he's competing against other men
this woman has the condition known as
DSD
and if as Sharon Davis says if you were
a runner and you were constantly beaten
by caster Semenya or you're a young
woman who wanted to compete against
caster Semenya you're going to be
distant disenfranchised discouraged just
disenchanted with your opportunities and
she's right ultimately there will be no
female records she must be allowed to
compete she needs her own classification
as to others with conditions similar I
would love to compete against our
honeymoon sprinters but sadly I find
myself not having the same physique as
them all elite athletes by definition
have elite physical advantages she is
totally different from the transgender
people conflate the gym no but in the
grab that we had she kind of later she
conveyed the truth this is not someone
who's chosen to transition this is
somebody who is a woman who has high
testosterone may Lily I see testes male
elite athlete I'll come back in if I
were a little javelin from right now
make okay let's just define the syndrome
that you refer to
it's called AIS and it's caused by a
genetic fault that's usually passed on
to a child by their mother now the word
fault isn't my wording just to make that
clear despite being genetically male the
body doesn't respond to testosterone
properly and male sexual development
doesn't happen as normal the penis
doesn't form or is underdeveloped which
means the Charles genitals may appear
female or between male and female
however they don't have a womb or
ovaries and have fully or partially
undescended testicles I want to say
after looking at this I yeah okay I was
right well partially all be about after
looking at this I want to say that I
really thought hard about this and I
come down on your side yeah first thing
I'd like says this isn't the same as a
transcendence at all
I don't you didn't second thing I'd say
is Phelps I love that analogy
it's what's wanna me is what did it for
me because what viewers may not know is
that Phelps has a wingspan
as in if he does that of six foot seven
inches
the other thing is he produces half the
lactic acid of you and me probably so
which means what does that mean that's
ik acid half the lactic acids produced
in the body now because it's an Atlantic
acid that your muscles build up when you
workout that makes you tired it's that
kind of strain feeling you getting the
muscles if it's producing half of that
it means it's getting tired less now why
is that Ferris why is it fair if I
compete against him I might be and when
you said but he's still competing in a
male cat it's the point is yes there
isn't a binary there's a spectrum if
I've got less of all of those things
than him then maybe I'm closer to a
woman please before I bring Michelle in
and just to say in terms of whether or
not she's a woman the athletics body
themselves classified her as a woman
don't forget this thing's been going on
since she started in sports and the poor
woman had to undergo horrific testing to
prove that she actually was female and
that was decided so as far as I'm
concerned it's done which is what in it
well this is such a complicated
discussion because it's not it's not
black or white and its really its own
brands argument and I know you must feel
awful talking about somebody in this way
is there like some kind of commodity but
it for me
women's class in these kind of events
were set up because you know if I was to
go head-to-head with my male equivalent
he is going to have unless it's Nick
he's gonna have he's gonna be stronger
than me he's gonna have I'm sorry he's
gonna have more power about him he's
gonna have more strength about him
probably and based on his physicality so
therefore we had to set up a separate
class for women so that we weren't
disadvantaged in terms of competing for
minerals would hardly ever win but using
that criteria yeah she underwent all of
the tests necessary because don't forget
early in the early days of sports they
actually used to test people to see
whether they were male or female yeah
and then that stopped and 60s but my
point is using the criteria that they
have in place the defected herb did
whether you're male or female they did
and she passed the female test that's it
as far as I'm concern I mean I could be
mistaken isn't it so you have to look at
how that's defined and I think and I
think that you said nay cause someone
said I'll maybe I just got in my own
head if we're looking at levels of
testosterone and an X and y chromosomes
and someone is found to have increased
levels of testosterone surely there can
be no and a y-chromosome
there can be no disputing that that
person has a physical advantage as does
Michael felt yes but Michael Phelps for
example if he's got long arms it's got
long arms as I understand it in this
particular case you can do a situation
where you can level your the reduce the
levels of testosterone down to more even
playing field explaining why they
decided that she couldn't compete as she
is the panel found that the DSD
regulations are discriminatory but the
majority of the panel found that on the
basis of the evidence submitted by the
parties in the procedure such
discrimination is a necessary reasonable
and proportionate means of achieving the
Ida believes objective of preserving the
integrity of female athletics in some
track events I think we're gonna look
back in there anything as such a
regressive stance but we don't that we
try to change the woman to meet our idea
of I want to say one thing don't forget
this is the same thing not quite the
same but very similar that they did
which is surya bonaly remember the
bigger skating champion who was able to
complete lots of tasks that nobody else
could do and as a result they penalized
her because she was better than
everybody else
it's no way something a question
Michelle asked because I think the
analogy to that to the arms isn't as
accurate as the analogy to them what we
wouldn't do is say to Phelps you've got
to have an extra dose of lactic acid
just to make it fair might be jealous no
but my point is if you want to run
against this woman who keeps on winning
there is a level of envy that's going to
arise and perhaps that's influencing the
way somebody create a level fair playing
field as much as possible this race has
been run